[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of New Avengers endgame trailer
footage to break down I know there's a
lot of questions about what's going on
with the next trailer they just screened
a whole bunch of new footage that also
included Captain Marvel in it so we'll
do a new round of the IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a marbled
comment on the video and I'll say
general spoiler warning for the Captain
Marvel post-credit scene because we'll
have to talk about that because it has
something to do with this brand-new
footage so I had a special Disney
investors meeting they screened actually
a pretty long scene with a whole bunch
of new footage pretty much all new
footage that we haven't seen before but
it started with the events of the
Captain Marvel post-credits scene so I
broke all these scenes down top 10 style
starting number 10 with the events of
the Captain Marvel post-credit scene
they play out Captain Marvel arrives at
the Avengers base shortly after the end
of Avengers infinity war in the events
of the snap Captain America has his trim
beard washed his hair Black Widow still
has short blonde hair Captain America
Black Widow counting the dead all over
the world in one of the labs in the
Avengers base the body counter just
keeps climbing and climbing super fast
Captain America can't believe it Bruce
Banner who still has not turned into the
Hulk because it's only been a short
while is when one of the other labs in a
different room examining something we
can't see and keeping an eye on Nick
Fury's pager which they have since found
roadie comes to get Captain America and
Black Widow and says that the pager
stopped doing whatever it's doing
they're still confused about what's
going on Captain America says they need
to stay on it because it was important
to fury in the pager has stopped
transmitting its signal black widow says
she wants them to tell her the minute
that they get a signal she wants to know
who fury was trying to contact she turns
around and predictably as you would
expect Captain Marvel is just standing
there like a ninja
none of them having realized that she's
entered the Avengers facility and says
very quietly where's fury her costume is
scuffed up a little bit her hair's a
little bit longer it's been 20 years but
her powers help her age much more slowly
the reason her shoulder guards look gold
in this is because it's just the
original costume with the red shoulder
guards that had been scuffed off or
fallen off during some battle in the
intervening years that she's been gone
in outer space a lot of questions about
whether or not she was wearing a
different costume during Avengers end
game the Russo brothers did shoot that
Captain Marvel
credit scene so it is a scene from
avengers endgame that they just copy
pasted to the end of the Captain Marvel
movie but the only thing I can say as to
why this costume might functionally look
different is because the people that
were shooting Avengers endgame and
Avengers infinity war just constructed
the same suit for Captain Marvel it just
looked a little bit different wasn't the
exact same soup but it's meant to be
pretty much the same suit the number
nine next part of the scene there's a
short time jump Captain Marvel is with
them and she says we need to go kill
thanos Rocket Raccoon is with them in
the room and he says that they saw the
single-biggest surge of energy ever on
earth when Thanos used the glove to snap
everyone out of existence but then they
detected the exact same energy signature
on a different planet in the galaxy
somewhere else so it was just them
putting two and two together oh this is
where Thanos went when he portals
himself away
number eight nebula and Iron Man have
made it back to earth but Iron Man and
ant-man aren't in any of this part of
the scene so presumably they're off
working on other stuff maybe it has
something to do with ant man's quantum
technology well Captain America Black
Widow Rhodey
Captain Marvel are trying to figure out
where Thanos is continuing to argue
nebula steps in from the shadows because
she's made it back and says I know where
he is seven she goes on to say while he
was perfecting me making all those
changes every time she lost she tells
that story during guardians of the
galaxy - every time she lost a fight
against Gamora he would modify her to
make her quote-unquote stronger in a
better fighter
so she says while he was perfecting me
he talked about where we go when it was
all finished even disassembled I would
want to please him so I would ask father
where will we go it his answer was
always the same and she talks about the
garden so six the place they're all
talking about is the garden where Thanos
went on Titan - which is what the Russos
called it on the set of Avengers
infinity war at the end of that movie
where he sits down and he takes his
armor off to make the Scarecrow from the
comics it's the same place that we've
seen him in all the Avengers end game
trailer scenes like particularly here
where he's brushing the flowers with the
charred Gauntlet which is still on his
hand obviously you can't tell when this
is happening during the movie this is
them just wanting to let you know where
he is and the fact that he still has the
gauntlet so this is actually a much
better look at the final scene from
infinity
war where he sat down look at how messed
up his arm is there were a lot of people
that assumed he healed himself
completely with the gauntlet when he
portal himself to this Titan to farm
where he's sitting but it's clear that
not all the damage was reversible or
maybe he just wanted to keep his
injuries as a reminder five roadie
chimes in in jokes
nice Thanos has a retirement plan so
they're all just like chuckling like
what the hell are we gonna do about this
for Bruce Banner asks what guarantees
they have that this ends differently
this time Captain Marvel responds you
have me this time we've seen how
powerful she is when she's in full
binary form at the end of the Captain
Marvel movie so they've gained
themselves another tank in their little
raid group which will help but they
don't know how powerful she'll be
against Thanos with the full gauntlet so
they're taking a lot of this on faith
because Captain Marvel looks like she
could be really powerful but obviously
they just have to take her at her word
about what she's capable of doing three
rody is sort of the voice of the fandom
when he says where was she this whole
time because they could have used her
before and Captain Marvel responds that
a lot of other planets out there need
help and they don't have an Avengers
team like Earth has so this sort of her
way of justifying why she was busy
increase girl space trying to stop their
war this whole time like she says she's
going to do at the end of the Katherine
Marvel movie tell the supreme
intelligence that I'm coming to end your
war and all the lies - Thor gets up from
sitting quietly in the background walks
up to Captain Marvel summons
Stormbreaker right into his hand which
whizzes right past Captain Marvel
remember this is a giant axe he sort of
goes toe to toe with her she doesn't
back down or anything like that they
have their bit of gunslingers standoff
moment he says I like this one the
number one you cut to the Bennet are the
guardians of the galaxy ship which Iron
Man and nebula macgyvered their way back
on with everyone buckled up Captain
Marvel in the copilot seat Iron Man and
ant-man aren't in any of these scenes
when they're on the Bennet are so I
think this corresponds to some of the
scenes that we've seen in the first big
trailer where Captain America has shaved
his beard off and he's talking to Black
Widow and he's wearing his different
Winter Soldier uniform they're standing
on the back of that ship now based on
this new footage it seems like they're
on the guardians of the galaxy ship when
that's happening rocket asks everyone
who has not been to space before
Captain America Rhodey Black Widow
raised their hands
rocket warns them not to puke on his
ship and then they take off there's a
cool reflection of stars in space on
Captain America's eye as you zoom in on
him and they warp out then that's
basically the end of the footage that
they've shown off some of that might
make it into the official Avengers
in-game trailer - when they drop that
yes I do think that it's gonna be when
tickets go on sale that's supposed to be
sometime at the beginning of April but
that's just a loose estimation that date
could change and I wouldn't expect all
this footage to make it into that
because this was a bunch of different
clips just jammed together it wasn't an
actual trailer trailers are way more
jumpy and they cut dialogue from other
scenes with different footage so it'll
look a little bit different but it does
sound like while all this stuff is going
on at the Avengers base with these
Avengers Iron Man is off working on
quantum realm quantum energy technology
stuff with ant-man trying to figure out
a way to track down either all the gems
there's a lot of speculation about how
they're gonna be using quantum energy
yes there have been a lot of rumors
about plot leaks and all that stuff I
usually wait to find out about that
stuff because a lot of it turns out to
be bogus so just be skeptical if someone
says they have the entire plot of
Avengers endgame worked out because it's
probably gonna wind up being false all
this footage confirms is that there will
be a group of people that just try to
straight-up go after Thanos on Titan 2
and fight him there whether or not it
winds up going down that way or things
go sideways while they're on their way
to go get Danos remains to be seen it
just sounds like they have a couple of
different groups trying different
methods to track him down just remember
that Ant Man and Iron Man were seen in
all these behind-the-scenes pictures at
the original Avengers fight way back
during that movie so there are ways to
explain how you have a version of
Captain America wearing this uniform his
Winter Soldier uniform running around
with this group of people but you also
have a classic version of him wearing
the old Avengers uniform with his old
shield walking around with Iron Man
because he also has one of those wrist
devices on so as we get more footage it
only makes the plot seem more
complicated and more twisty but we'll
find out when we get that next trailer
leave all your theories about how these
different teams are split up and what
they're up to in the comments
none of the footage tells you exactly
what it is the Iron Man and nebula do to
change the benatar to help them get back
home only that they do
and it also implies that when they're
outside in the Superbowl trailer that
they released all looking up at the sky
that's probably the Benatar that's
arriving just because it looks so big in
the frame is so wide there are a lot of
people that are wondering how Captain
Marvel is able to surprise Black Widow
in Captain America because it doesn't
seem like anybody would ever be able to
sneak up behind them and Surprise them I
think it's mostly just in service of the
big twist where you know she turns
around and you're like oh my god it's
Captain Marvel and she's with the
Avengers and everybody freaks out in the
movie theater during the post-credits
scene in reality she probably just flew
in to the Avengers facility and was able
to counteract any of their defense
mechanisms whereas Ant Man is stuck in
the van and unless he's trying to get
something specifically like when he was
stealing something from the Avengers
base way back during the original
ant-man movie he's just gonna stand at
the door and try to get their attention
obviously he could put the suit on and
sneak into the Avengers base but I don't
think that they're looking for a moment
like that to introduce him to the
Avengers especially in this particular
trailer that they released so just
remember just because characters have
certain powers and abilities doesn't
mean that that's the way that they're
going to use them during the course of
the movie but it does seem like Captain
Marvel in ant-man are not like the two
most important characters on the team
particularly ant-man because of his
access to quantum energy in the quantum
realm there's been a bunch of comic-book
news the past week so leave all your
video requests in the comments below
they'll be more Marvel coming soon -
while you wait for everything click here
for all my Captain Marvel Easter eggs
and click here for that Captain Marvel
post-credits scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]